John 10:17:18
For this reason the father loves me
because I lay my life down of my own
accord. No one can take it away from me.
Yes, he chose John 10. That's why he
said, "God, why have you forsaken?" Are
you you want to go back to that? You
want me to embarrass you with that
again? Do you know the context of that?
Do you know the context of Mark 15:34?
Contradiction chose to die
to me. No. Let me tell you why there's
no contradiction. Because being an ignor
Amos, you don't know where he's quoting
from. Mark 15:34, "My God, my God, why
have you forsaken me?" He's quoting
Psalm 22:1. Can I now explain to you
what he means so you don't make that
argument again?
Sure. Okay. Let's go to Psalm 22:1.
That's what he's quoting. Okay, let's go
there. So he So he's just quoting. No,
if you let me finish the point, you're
going to get school. If you let me
finish more, you're going to get school.
Here's what he's quoting. Psalm 22:1.
Psalm 22:1. To the chief musician said
to the dear of the dawn, a psalm of
David, "My God, my God, why have you
forsaken me?" Now, let's finish it. Why
are you so far from helping me from the
words of my groaning? Jesus's words
isn't why you've abandoned me. His words
are, "How much longer will I remain in
this condition where I'm under the
judgment for sin when it's now finished,
done with, over with?" It's not, "Oh,
why are you forsake?" It's how much
longer will I remain this predicament?
It's all finished. The sin, the sin debt
has been paid. It's over. And then guess
what happens when Jesus said that? The
darkness was removed because God
answered him, "Son, it is over. Time to
come home." That's when he says,
"Father, into your hands I commit my
spirit." So, it's not, "Oh my God, why'd
you forsaken me, father?" No, no. It's,
"Father, all things are finished.
I have fulfilled your will. I have drunk
the cup. The debt of sin is paid. How
much more longer will the judgment last
now that all things are finished?" And
the answer is it's over, son. That's why
the darkness vanished. And then he says,
"Father, in trans I commit my spirit."
So don't quote passages out of context
when you need to read passages in
context because you're going to keep
embarrassing yourself.
That's fine. I won't quote passages out
of context. But even the way that you
just explained it right now, it sounds
like a father or a god talking to a
human. It doesn't sound like two gods
that are all knowing talking. And I
don't believe there are two gods. Number
one, I don't believe there are two gods,
two persons. And why can't one speak to
the other? Especially Jesus trying to
signify to people in front of him, I am
fulfilling the prophecy. And now see
that the father hears and does
everything I ask. That's actually a sign
from Jesus to show he's the almighty son
who gets whatever he wants because the
father does everything that the son
asks. What are you talking about? But
now it's going to a sign that he says,
"Why have what?" Yes. Because did God
answer him right away and remove the
darkness? Yes or no?
Yes. That's a sign that I am the
almighty son of God who gets whatever I
want from the father because the father
always does what I ask. And that's in
John 11:41-44. But before I go there,
you sure you want to use this argument?
Yeah, I want to use the argument. You
sure? Because you know Arabic, right?
Yeah, I guess you know Arabic, right? My
Arab I know Arabic. Go to Surah Bakar.
Go to Surah Bak 2 verse 157.
157. Because your God prays. Who does he
pray to? Read for me the Arabic slowly.
Surah chapter 2 verse 157.
[Music]
Repeat that word again.
Salawat. Right. Mhm. And then finish it.
Okay.
What does the word salawat mean?
Blessings. You wicked liar. The word
blessing is baraka.
You think you're going to lie to me and
get away with it. The word salawat is
plural for salah. The word for blessing
is baraka is blessing. Barakat would be
blessings. The word salawat means
prayers. Why would you lie to me? Yeah,
I'm not lying. I'm reading
international. Forget sahi international
for the love of your God. What is the
word prayers in Arabic? Say the word
prayers in Arabic. Salat. Say it again.
Salah. And then what's salawat?
Prayer is plural. Oh, so you just admit
it. It says the prayers of your Lord is
upon them. What prayers of your Lord?
Your Lord has prayers.
Yeah, he can. He can. Oh, so your God
can pray, but Jesus can't pray to the
father. Wow, you inconsistent hypocrite.
How is that inconsistent? God can Why
can't Jesus pray to the father and still
be God? If you're God, Allah can pray
and still be God.
Did I say Jesus can't pray together?
Yeah, you just said that earlier. It
sounds like a human being speaking to
God, not to God, speaking to each other.
Yeah, you just said that. What are you
talking about? That was your argument. I
didn't say I didn't say anything about
prayer. I just said it sounds like
somebody is uncertain.
How can it be uncertain when he's saying
it's time to be reconciled? It is now
over because I have drunk the cup fully.
It is finished. Because the psalmist is
telling you it's not oh god how okay
it's done with time to come home. You
know you can ask a question not because
you're looking for an answer but ask a
question in order to put someone on the
spot or to get your request. In other
words here I'll give you example in the
book of Quran when Abraham asked Allah
to show him how he gives life to the
dead. Didn't Allah ask him a question.
Why do you doubt? Why was he asking a
question?
Why do you don't? Because he's testing
his faith. But why does he ask? Sure
sounds like Allah's a human being who's
asking a human being to help him
understand a question.
No, he knows. But he's helping him
understand. But when Jesus asks
questions, it immediately assumes he's
ignorant. You see your inconsistency
again? Uh the difference is that you're
saying Jesus is God, though. But Allah
is God. Allah is the one who's telling
Muham Abraham, why are you doubting me?
Correct. So, how can Allah ask? I
thought he's God. He knows everything.
He does know everything. Why is he
asking?
He's not asking out of ignorance. Oh,
but Jesus must be asking out of
ignorance. You see why you're
inconsistent?
Uh, but what you're saying though is
that Jesus already knew. That's
different. Just like Allah already knew.
No, no. Just like Allah already knew.
Allah already knew what Abraham was
going to say but he asked anyway. Or in
Maida, let me finish the point. Listen
to the point. Surah Maida 5 verse 116.
Allah will ask Jesus, "Oh Jesus, son of
Mary, did you tell the people take you
and your mother as two gods? You
ignorant Allah, don't you know the
answer? Why are you asking?" You see
your logic what you just did? No,
because exactly what you said that you
just answered the own question. That's
Thank you. So then Oh my goodness. I'm
gonna hit my head against the wall. Hold
on. Talking to humans. Okay, let me hit
my head against the wall. Why is Allah
asking Jesus?
Why is Allah asking Jesus if Jesus told
people did you, you know, worship me in
my mother as two gods when Allah knows?
Jesus didn't ask that. So why is he
asking? Why is Allah who's not a man
asking?
Why is he asking what? Why is he asking
Jesus? Did you tell mankind to take you
and your mother's two gods when he
supposedly knows Jesus never asked or
told people that and he's no? So why is
he asking again?
This is in the Quran. Yeah. Chapter 5
verse 116.
Okay. Chapter 5 verse 116. Mhm.
We got to finish up because I got to go
do another live stream. Okay. But why
why is he asking? Whatever answer you
give, pay attention. That's the same
thing with Jesus. Jesus can ask
questions not because he's ignorant.
Just like if Allah can ask questions,
not because he's ignorant. He has a
reason to ask, but automatically in your
mind, oh, see, Jesus is a man. He
doesn't know everything. That's like,
stop being inconsistent. That's all I'm
telling you. Stop. It's not It's not
inconsistent. But but because according
to Islam, Jesus was a man. So it makes
sense. But it's not Jesus asking. It's
Allah asking. Hello.
It's Allah asking a man. It's not Jesus
the man asking. It's Allah the all
knowing God asking Jesus. Why Allah?
Don't you already know the answer?
Allah. Exactly. Get stuck for Allah. So
why is Allah whom you think is all
knowing asking Jesus the man if he went
around telling people did you tell
people take you and your mother as gods?
Doesn't Allah already know? Why is he
asking? Of course he already knows. Why
is he asking?
I can't answer that question. I'm not
God. Okay. So then don't ever Here's the
point. Don't ever question Jesus's deity
because he asks. Because if you're going
to do that, bury Allah and the Quran
because Allah prays and asks. So
according to you, Allah is less than
human. Is Jesus God? And is Jesus the
God man? Is Jesus God? Is he the God
man? Yes or no? According to my belief,
yeah, I'm asking. Okay. Now, is Allah
God? Answer. Is Allah God? Yes. And he
prays.
He doesn't pray. Yes. You just read the
verse. Prayers. Yes. Huge. Okay. Go to
chapter 33:43. Let me end it with you.
Go to chapter 33:43. Great. Okay. Go to
33:43. Great. It's not like God gives
salah every day. Yes, he does. Chapter
33:43. Chapter 33 verse 43. This is now
10 times. I just said it. Chapter 33:43.
43. Yeah. Read it for me. Okay.
Hold on. 33. 43. Two more verses and I
got to go because it's almost time for
me to go to Oh, man. I'm late as it is.
Okay. 3343. Read it for me. 33. It is he
who confers blessing upon you. Okay.
What's the Arabic word? Don't give me
the English butchering. What's the
Arabic word? Okay.
What does means
pray? So it is he who prays for you and
the angels.
Yeah. So Allah is praying with the
angels to guide believers out of
darkness into light.
No, in that context it just blessings.
No, it's not blessing because the angels
also do salah. And angels, the only way
they bless is by asking Allah to bless.
Don't play games with me. Allah and the
angels pray. Allah and the angels pray.
So when angels pray, they pray to Allah.
When Allah prays, is he praying to
himself?
Now go to 33:56.
33:56.
Okay. Yeah. Go learn my Bible and then
learn your religion because you don't
know either. And stop attacking my
Bible. 33 verse 56. Rude. Well, it's
true. You talk about rude. You want me
to start on Muhammad again? Allahb
3356. So we can end it. Indeed. Allah
confers blessing upon No, that's not
what the Arabic says. Oh my goodness,
man. Dude, aren't you ashamed of
yourself? Read 3356
in the Arabic, please. Slowly. All
right. You just said do it in English
because But your English translation is
butchering the Arabic. Read the Arabic.
That's why for everybody watching, just
learn Arabic if you want to learn
because Allah Allah's handicap. Yeah,
guys. Allah's handicap. He can only
understand you in Arabic. So learn
Arabic because Allah's handicap. Can you
read 3356?
Is that what you're looking for? Yeah.
Read it slowly.
Okay. Allah and who?
Angels do what?
Blessing. Oh my goodness. You're such a
shameful liar. Pray. Fine. Prayer. Okay.
Allah and angels do what?
Pray. Pray for who?
Pray for who? The prophet. So we know
when angels pray for your prophet, they
pray to Allah. Who does Allah pray to
when he prays for your prophet?
He's praying for the prophet. He's not
praying for Yeah. But I pray for you.
See, you didn't hear me. I pray for you.
When I pray for you, I got to pray to
someone when I pray for you. So when the
angels pray for Muhammad, who do they
pray to?
God. So when Allah prays for your
prophet, who does he pray to?
Nobody because he is God. So then who's
he praying to when he prays for
Muhammad? Because it says he and the
angels pray for. It's not a prayer to
prayer. I'm going to repeat it again.
Angels are praying for Muhammad also.
Allah and the angels pray for Muhammad.
But when the angels pray for Muhammad,
they're praying to someone. Who does
your God Allah pray to when he prays for
Muhammad?
He's not praying to anybody because he's
God. So then when he prays for Muhammad,
he's got to be praying to somebody. Who?
Why? That's because it says Allah and
the angels pray. Both of them. Allah and
the angels are praying. They're doing
the same action. It's right there in
front of your eyes. Allah and the angels
pray.
That's correct. But that's your logic is
that So now here's what you learned,
sister. We're going to end it here. We
got to end it. Never ever dare attack
Jesus because every argument you use, I
just used to bury Allah. No, you don't.
Okay. Okay, sister. Anyway, guys, God
bless you. I'm late. I gotta contact
this guy. Take care.